we are very excited about our next guest
trailblazing actress sonia manzano she's
best known for playing maria on sesame
street for 44 years writing for the show
won her 15 emmy awards and a lifetime
achievement emmy she's also a prolific
children's book writer manzano's newest
historical novel for pre-teens is called
coming up cuban it's about four
different experiences and backgrounds
affected by the cuban revolution in the
late 1950s and early 60s and sonia
manzano is here it is such a pleasure to
have you in studio good morning well
thank you good morning it's a pleasure
for me to be here so talk to us about
this book coming up cuban and the
inspiration because it's told through
the eyes of four teens uh and their
different experiences uh during that
time well you'll appreciate this story
this is how it started i'm at a party
at a book party and a gentleman a united
states citizen said that he was uh his
father had a chicken farm in cuba in
1959 wow castro comes in
nationalizes everything the family has
to leave immediately sadly they leave
the family dog behind boohoo i said oh
i'm so sorry you left your dog behind
him he said no worries the dog showed up
in a boat in miami four months later wow
well i thought well this is a hilarious
little picture right but when i started
looking uh reading
more about the revolution to sort of
round out the simple picture book story
i realized how many other things
happened kids uh families were separated
kids came with their families some kids
came alone with the operation pedro pan
then i thought
well these are the kids who left what
happened to the kids who stayed well
then i had to read about those kids and
that's what inspired four different
stories about the effects of the
castro's revolution so the book is
geared towards middle school-aged kids
which are some of the most important
years of their lives what do you want
them to take away from it well i'm
hoping that
that they get inspired and they get uh
hope from it you know we're letting them
down so much we can't protect them in
school that well
uh we can't help them get into community
colleges either what we can do or what i
can do is give them stories because when
you put yourself in the life of another
kid who's successful
and prevails you say oh i got sixth
grade i mean you know he got past castro
he had to leave home he had to go to
military school that he didn't want to
and they prevailed and sort of it gives
it gives our children or the reader
hope that they could overcome their
problems and change their narrative
stories changed my narrative i went to
stories when i was a kid i loved to read
about other kids and how they did and
how they succeeded so i'm thinking this
book will do that not about learning
about castro
right they could do that on wikipedia
this is about social relationships these
kids have you have so many projects
still going uh you just renewed a second
season with um alma's way yes yes and
you're looking at doing books with that
as well yes what keeps you going and are
you inspired by the children's
programming that you see now
knowing that you were on this
groundbreaking show
for 44 years well i'm inspired by kids
you look at a bunch of kids and you say
who can sing and dance they all raise
their hands right so they all have
uh uh enthusiasm for living and i of
course sesame street came out of the 60s
that's why it was successful so when i
was asked to create the show for pbs i
looked around and i said what is society
what's happening with kids now right
what's happening now we expect a lot
from them they have to be tested they
have to be
memorized and a lot of kids who can't do
that think oh i'm not smart so i thought
let me create this show amma's way which
is about thinking it actually shows the
thinking process so we did get picked up
uh for a second season uh pbs so we're
very happy about that well i know i can
speak for so many thank you for your
contributions oh thank you to the
culture and to education raising so many
children and you look great
what is the key to staying young forever
i think it's that muppet makeup there it
is
so you manzano thank you so much coming
up cuban is on sale now
and